welcome welcome good to have you were
y'all from Montana what do you guys do
for a living I'm an electrician at a
power plant and I was a receptionist at
a fitness center since we've become
debt-free I've been able to stay home
and be with Isaac and take care of him
and nobody else has to raise him we are
then in Montana now 15 years Joe was the
single dad on food stamps and tried to
make ends meet you know when we met I
was out with some friends and hung I ran
into him I was out by myself we're at
the bar I was sitting at the girls
bathroom at the entrance by a bear rug
and so I would talk to all the girls
coming and going and she was the only
one that sat down and we had a
conversation and told her here's my
number give me a holler for yourself I
don't take guys numbers and I was like
well okay give me your number
and as soon as we got home I called her
up and asked her if she wanted to go
have breakfast and we hit it off ever
since I thought he was a rich cowboy
when I met him Mambo Lala's broke
[Music]
I never was taught money we always
talked to work my mom was a single mom
and she worked 40 plus hours a week as a
nurse so I kind of followed in my mom's
footsteps and began working as early as
I could and one of my co-workers had the
book the Total Money Makeover
I was curious and she let me bring the
book home and I brought it to him I said
man I ain't got time for that build my
house and we're gonna continue on it
there was a lot of blame it's like why
am I gonna listen her she can't get the
bills paid in time but it wasn't her it
was me it was me not taking charge of my
household so Joe what flip the switch
for you tell us what happened now we're
into 2011 we have to go to Texas name a
stepmom I had an uncle tell me if you
want to get to where she's going some
things you got changing your laugh and
that's okay here we go again this old
man's gonna talk to me about my drinking
and but that was the turning point I
called the pastor over to the house and
said what kind of church are you what do
you teach what do you preach and who are
you we were both where God wanted us um
because he had something big in store
for us he had our daughter Brecon um
through the entire pregnancy we knew
that there was something wrong there was
complications her bones were small her
phones weren't normal we were very open
with our story just to get prayer
support encouragement because you need
all that when you're going through a
tough time and we were very hopeful and
very joyful our friends Matt Bethany
gave us a gift and we actually held on
to it was a cheque we held on to the
check and then we ended up opening an
account in Brecon name before she was
born
when Joey Jackie were going through
there pretty big struggle with their
baby Brecon we just knew that that's
something that God was laying on her
hearts was to give out of our abundance
of blessings and the fact that we became
debt-free was the fact that we can give
I mean it was the first sign of
generosity in that amount that I've ever
seen in my life it changed my
perspective on a lot of stuff because
they said you're gonna need this when
she's born and we thought wow this is
awesome and uh they ended up also giving
us a gift and then we had our daughter
[Music]
well she ended up being born with what
is called campo Melek skeletal dysplasia
she lived for 65 days the gift came
right when we needed it because he was
able to stay with us and we were able to
just have that time with her and it was
it was awesome to be able to do that um
you know I immediately just wanted to
help people because I mean look what was
done for us and Joe was actually looking
at buying a brand-new truck $60,000 Joe
had mentioned that you know I really
want this truck I want it brand new I
want to order it I wanted exactly the
way that I want it I got home a horse's
back and forth and doing things to my
animals and the old truck that I have
that trucks wore out I just felt bad
immediately that wow what a mistake that
is gonna be and then he just kept
shaking his head it's a menu that can
screw up and just do to our relationship
I was able to speak into his life and
help him it says so if you're gonna go
out there buy this truck you're not
going to be able to go do what you want
to do ultimately and help other families
out I says well how did you do it
and then he told me about Dave Ramsey
and he said he showed me dumb I said I
believe Jackie's told me about this
Ramsey guy about five years ago Matt and
Bethany were putting on an FPU class
they gave me the kit and as a cool has a
book with it I'm 45 years old now
never in a book and it was the complete
guide to money so I took it to work and
I read it and it took me a few days and
then setting every but I read it as my
first book I finished and so I came home
and says we're going to do this we've
paid off seventy thousand nine hundred
ninety-nine and forty eight cents in
eighteen months
very proud of it sorry for the tragedy
that you've been through but you've got
blessings all around you in the midst of
it God is good he is all the time
Wow alright Joe and Jackie from the
Billings Montana area seventy one
thousand dollars paid off at 18 months
making a hundred and fifty a year count
it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
we want to go back to those knee cues we
want to go in there and help people out
you're not that is not being a devote
your energy road is play out there still
and so you got to have a vision a way
out there and then take the walk
[Music]